130 morts 1800 parties civiles 20
accusés le procès des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 a débuté à paris celui
septembre à midi un procès attendu six
ans après les faits pour clore le volet
judiciaire de cette affaire mais aussi
redouter un contexte un peu pesant ça ça
entre nos esprits la presse ne parle que
de cela je sais que les avocats des
parties civiles travaillent en
collaboration pour être efficace
pertinent et
je crois que le dossier qui a été
présenté à qui va être présenté à la
cour décide la cour d'assises spéciale
est plutôt béton trois attaques
perpétrés simultanément au bataclan au
stade de france et aux abords des
terrasses parisiennes thibault yvelinois
étaient venus assister au concert de
rock avec sa femme ce soir du 13
novembre 2015 il se souvient les fameux
bruit de pétard que beaucoup de
personnes ont rapporté et
donc j'ai attrapé mon épouse et nous
nous sommes allongées par terre
ou un moment j'ai relevé la tête pour et
la salle était allumée et j'ai vu au
niveau du par un homme un jeune homme
qui tirait sur les personnes qui étaient
au sol et c'est là que j'ai compris que
si on restait là on n'allait sans doute
pas on allait se faire tuer c'était
certain et si on essayait de partir bien
peut-être qu'on allait recevoir une
balle mais au moins j'aurai essayé
peut-être qu'on aurait aussi la chance
de sortir de là à chaque fois qu'ils on
entend une détonation d'une arme ou une
rafale on se disait que la prochaine et
peut-être pour nous le couple arrive à
rejoindre les loges une jeune femme
creuserait alors un trou dans le faux
plafond d'un cabinet de toilette endroit
par où ils s'échapperont ils resteront
trois heures immobile dans les combles
avant d'être secouru par le raid le raid
nous prépare nous organiser pour sortir
et quitter c'était le bataclan en
envoyant moins possible ce qui est voilà
on sort en file indienne en regardant
par terre
mais la vision périphérique vous avez
fait qu'on capte quand même des
informations et c'est le chaos absolu le
chaos est total il ya du sens absolument
partout et des éclats de balle il ya
c'est tout est cassé c'est tout est
dévasté c'est décors absolument partout
en aujourd'hui thibault fait partie de
l'association 13 ans 15 qui soutient les
victimes du 13 novembre il s'est porté
partie civile pour le procès selon lui
on ne passe pas à autre chose mais il
faut avancer on passera jamais à autre
chose c'est déjà par respect pour les
personnes qui ne sont pas sortis de là
parce qu'il ya une culpabilité très très
forte nous on a eu la chance de sortir
de là sans être blessé sans perdre
approche mais il ya quand même 80 90
personnes qui sont mortes
au bataclan le procès devrait durer neuf
mois pour un verdict en mai 2022 une web
radio dédiée uniquement aux parties
civiles victimes ne pouvant être
présentes a été mise en place pour
suivre le procès à distance